на згадку не двері град і навіки нахта
тварин вивісок
так виглядає і порожній офіс київську ЛГБТ
організації хвалитися розірву лярне
нападає а щоб не виникало проблем на
роботі я наприклад їм було Олександра
шварцмана, що не знав праворуч його
орієнтацію кривляється фірми пішло
торкнулася ти зарплати, а потім через
рольових багато ультиматум обидва
робота обидва вуса швидко жити а кирим не
далі далі говориться та ви його не
приймаю ось реакція ти майбутнє проти
ти
наші штамп про шкоду не сходяться чаю і ті
у місті ван і пасивним ну ти
здогадуюсь колії
Олександр прикутий про хвала на
верховну раду я поправка ситуацію з
правами лгбт спину ти до курей він
змінити джес тусується б малюка роботи
c аматорські відео маршу ревнощів ще
прошу руки і ви в черні
виглядають напарники у масках кидають у це
орда учасники у мирні худі
було одинадцять жертв 11 жертв нападе
друк машу ревнощів
сі он вивернулася a dog правах у рідних
органі та жадібність прав треба виловити та
джан з кейсами було доведено до кінця
артем ЛГБТ з пілота може за вишиті сіна
адже без зад virgin ую анти дисками
нативні поправки обожнюю журналіст
максим Еріставі і петелька рокки в тому
сам став жертвою дискримінації попри
на те, що її прийняли її по передпліччю і
у хвалив і включив цей 2 кодексу не
carrera ночі [ __ ] перестану 9 це
природно та нові новий трудовий
кодекс ще пройшов і погодження нами
статей спробуєш
повернути за те, що я все ти хочеш
повернутий і до нового закону МСУ
поправку з доводи ці око уват з
навчаться голосувати за багато олександр
шварцман же на ноги та роботі на плані та
приходять і сексуальну орієнтацію та
розум замші ми учасникам ароматики хору
нізації обіцяй оборот зник за
заощадження анти-дискримінації нові
поправки у новому кодексі